for songwriters it's the pinnacle the
elite club that includes giants from Bob
Dylan to jay-z George Gershwin to
Loretta Lynn for nearly 50 years the
Songwriters Hall of Fame has recognized
the achievements of the artists who put
words and music together to create the
soundtrack of our lives in a moment
we'll talk to the chairman of the
Songwriters Hall of Fame Nile Rodgers
he's co-founder of the group chic and a
man who's written produced and performed
on records that have cumulatively sold
more than 500 million albums worldwide
but first only on CBS this morning
Saturday it's our honor to introduce you
to the new inductees to the Songwriters
Hall of Fame the six artists who make up
the class of 2019
they are rapper Missy Elliott country
storyteller Tom T Hall hip-hop producer
Dallas Austin Jack tension songwriter
for the Eagles and Rock and Roll Hall of
Famers John Prine and Cat Stevens and
we're joined now by the chairman of the
Songwriters Hall of Fame Nile Rodgers
now first of all Missy Elliott first
hip-hop artist female hip-hop artist in
the Hall of Fame amazing it's amazing
you know to me it's important to have
equality like you know I've written with
a lot of women's songwriters but not
nearly enough
yeah and that's been my that's sort of
like my secret goal I want to have more
women songwriters and so that's why when
you told me Missy Elliott I'm like blown
away it's like she's one of my favorite
writers of all time Cat Stevens you you
saw just recently I just saw him he was
at Abbey Road you know because you've
been that road yeah and I couldn't
believe it I mean when I was a kid I
just worshipped cats East even so that I
mean I love this this is great yeah
you're in the Songwriters Hall of Fame
what does it mean to be in for a
singer-songwriter
you know songwriting is such a lonely
profession you know you do it at least
most of the time you do it sort of in
solitary and even when you have a
songwriting partner usually those
original motifs happen by
self yeah and when other people
recognize you it's something that's so
rewarding I don't even know how to
explain it because I don't think any of
us do it to be famous these are the
songwriters I know don't really do it to
be famous because usually that we're
storytellers there's a message that we
want to to communicate with others so it
just feels so wonderful to be on the
level of you know the the Richard Rogers
and this the how David's and the Burt
Bacharach sand the Berry Gordy's and you
know you grow up idolizing these people
and all of a sudden you're in that same
exclusive club yeah it's something I've
heard a lot of artists say which is as
cool as it might be to be in the Rock
and Roll Hall of Fame it actually means
more to songwriters to be here it feels
it really does you can be in the Rock
and Roll Hall of Fame for being a great
performer you know having terrific songs
that other people wrote yeah but this
you did it's all you it's you so what
did it mean to you to be in duck ah I
was blown away I mean I just felt like
now you finally made it you know there's
that thing that other people recognize
because it is lonely I mean you know no
one knows who songwriters are right
that's true I wrote we are family most
people don't know I wrote we are family
so you know they they hear and they see
Sister Sledge and they associated with
Sister Sledge
but they don't necessarily associated
with now Rodgers and Bernard Edwards
right like just most people right now
Rogers thanks so much for being with us
thank you happy